اخر اخبار جهودكم في عمليات الانقاذ وماذا
عن فرص بقاء منهم تحت الانقاض على قيد
الحياه مع تتابع الساعات
في الحقيقه حتى الان فرق الدفاع المدني لا
زال لا زالت تعمل داخل المواقع وترفع
الانقراض وتسحب العالقين من تحت الانقاض
للاسف فرص الحياه باتت محدوده جدا وبات
قليله وضعيفه الاعداد
التي تشير الى ارتفاع عدد الضحايا والقتله
هي الاعداد التي تتزايد يعني انتم الان
تكلمتم تكلمتم عن 1930 وانا سازيد هذا
الرقم حتى 1970 هو تحديد جديد يعني منذ
ساعات منذ ساعه او اقل من ساعه عدد
المصابين للاسف بات يبقى عمليا واقف بدون
اي زياده 2,950 مصاب هو نفس العدد الذي
يتكرر منذ الصباح تقريبا حتى هذه الساعه
هذا ان دل على شيء يدل على ان
فرص وجود العالقين بات ضعيفا وكما نعرف ان
في مثل هذه الكوار تكون دائما 72 ساعه هي
72 ساعه ذهبيه للعصول للحصول على عالقين
تحت الانقاض او سحب عالقين تحت الانقاض
وهم على قيد الحياه للاسف الفرص تتضاءل
بشده العمل لا زال مستمر منذ الدقائق
الاولى من وقوع هذه الكارثه لازال العمل
مستمر حتى الان لم يغادر فريق الدفاع
المدني مواقع العمل منذ اللحظه الاولى حتى
الان ولن يغادر هذه هل وصلتكم اي معلومات
عن الدخول ما طلبتوه من معدات
يعني معدات لانقاذ الضحايا
في الحقيقه للاسف لم تصل حتى هذه اللحظه
اي معدات
قمنا بطلبها من من كافه دول العالم قمنا
بارسال مناشدات من اللحظات الاولى لازلنا
نعتمد على المعدات المتوفره بين يدي فرق
القوات البيضاء والدفاع المدني لازلنا
نعتمد ايضا على بعض الاليات التي قام
بوضعها تحت تصرف القوات البيضاء المدنيين
الموجودين في شمال غرب سوريا ولازمنا
نعتمد على الفرق التطوعيه التي تدعم فرق
الخوز البيضاء 2800 متطوع من الفوز
يعمل في القوات البيضاء هو موجود في
الميدان ما يقارب الف متطوع من المدنيين
وضعوا نفسهم تحت تصرف الخوذ البيضاء طبعا
هم من الاشخاص الذين قام الدفاع المدني في
المراحل الماضيه قبل وقوع الزلزال
باعطائهم دورات تدريبيه حتى يكونوا هم
عونا للدفاع المدني في مثل هذه الكوارث
طبعا انت تعرف يعني على مدى اكثر من عشر
سنوات الدفاع المدني يقوم بعمليات سحب
العالقين من تحت الانقاذ جراء قصف نظام
بشار الاسد لهذه المناطق واستهداف هذه
الابنيه ودائما
الانقاض موجوده منذ عشر سنوات حتى الان
فلذلك
التكفل بهم علاجيا هل هناك امكانيات كافيه
علاجيه
في الحقيقه يعني المصاعد كثيره يعني
المصاعد موجوده مع المصابين تحت الانقاض
وعندما نستخرج المصاب من تحت الالفاظ
ينتقل من صعوبه الى صعوبه اخرى هي المشافي
وقدره المشافي الاستيعابيه على استقبال
هذه الاصابات واستقبال هذه هؤلاء المصابين
طبعا ايضا
المشافي هي مستنفره بشكل كامل الاطقم
الطبيه مستنفره بشكل كامل تعمل منذ اللحظه
الاولى حتى الان ولكن ايضا طاقتها
الاستيعابيه وقدرتها على الاستجابه باتت
يعني ضعيفه بشكل كبير وايضا هناك مناشدات
كثيره من المشافي والعاملين الطبيين من
اجل العمل على يعني وصول مساعدات طبيه
لهذه المشافي والكوادر الطبيه تدعم عمل
هؤلاء الفرق الطبيه الموجوده في الم